the whole crisis the whole financial
crisis the 2008 financial crisis
when you were in high school um you know
that's basically
that that was based on subprime loans
that were bad
[Music]
you know that they were saying were
triple a subprime loans
and they were actually cpa they were
going to
where did that start in pennsylvania
what's the first
when they when people first started
going to
like houses in the projects people that
had were like like low income
areas they started knocking on doors and
saying hey
we think your house is worth this we
could re-fought we could re get you a
new mortgage on your house
i would think that was going on
everywhere that they were subprime i i
don't know that there was a
uh like you're talking about like a
ground zero
like yeah where basically before the
like the thing that like set the
financial crisis off
right but you have to understand prior
to that there was what's called the the
savings and loan crisis
you know there was a there was a crisis
before that there was a crisis there's
always
every seven to ten years there's some
kind of crisis you know that we're due
for another crisis
right um so i mean it's it's
i'm talking about legitimate fraud that
was going on with lots of with
lots of lenders where they were
basically going to people
in like poverty areas poverty areas
where people were
where they would knock on people's doors
right
and they would say hey we can get you a
new mortgage on your house
and you could your house will be worth
this much more and you get this much
money out of your house people are like
oh wow this is great right
and ibor city yeah exactly what you were
doing exactly what you were doing but it
was like actual like mortgage brokers
that were like
lots of them that were doing this and
like like specifically screwing people
out of
out of their own houses instead of you
you were creating fake identities
right well i mean you know they would
you would basically that would fall on
you've heard the term predatory lending
predatory lending you're lending people
money that you basically know they can't
pay back
right and you're you're preying on
people that don't have the financial
understanding
to figure out that what they're signing
is going to come back and bite them in
the ass
you know and then you've got people that
argue okay well they they had a chance
they signed they this
they knew they knew you know well i mean
yeah they knew but
it was a lot of money up front and they
they people always assume
that they're going to be doing better in
two years when the
when the arm hits when the you know
adjustable rate mortgage hits
you know they lend you the money at five
percent you're not thinking about two
years when it jumps to
to six percent and then six months later
it jumps to
6.9 then seven months later it jumps to
8.1 you're not thinking about that
right now you're thinking i'm gonna
you're gonna give me fifty thousand
dollars
you guys never seen 50 grand in his life
yeah his house is he's like i bought
that house for 35 000
i've owned it for five years you're now
telling me where it's worth 150.
you're gonna give me 50 grand and my
payments only going to go up by a
hundred dollars
wow heck yeah i could i can turn that
money into something you're right right
so what happens is then you lend your
cousin some money and he's going to pay
you back he's going to open up a
restaurant
you're going to invest that money here
and here for you know it you realize
that most of the people you know are
scumbags
they don't pay you back and you're on
the hook for the money
and by the time you really figure out
hey
that money really blew through my
fingers pretty quickly
and then all the furniture new furniture
that i bought isn't worth anything and
that new car is not worth [ __ ] and now
it's two years and guess what
my 590 payment just jumped to
6.95 and six months later it's now
808.10
and now you're screwed yeah and now i
can't pay it anymore
yeah you know and my my taxes went up
and my insurance and
it's just you know just and then they go
back and foreclose on you and then they
foreclose and they watch
what they planned on doing from the
start well i don't think that they net
i don't know if they necessarily planned
on doing that really i don't know i i
don't know
i i don't know i i've heard look the
bank what i do know is the bank doesn't
want your house
you know everybody's like oh they want
the house yeah but here's what they what
they did though
after they foreclose they can just
repeat that process
with the next person they sell the house
to i mean that's true there was actually
a guy there was actually a guy well
sometimes that but keep in mind too what
if the house wasn't worth that much and
they lose when they foreclose they
typically lose like 20 percent
usually what happens when they do that
they sell those off so that by the time
it goes bad
it doesn't come back two years later
doesn't come back on the original bank
it comes back on the investor or this
the subprime or the secondary
secondary purchaser of that mortgage
so you've packaged them together people
are paying you get rid of them by the
time
by the time that hits uh-oh 25
25 69 cents 69 cents
it hurts my feelings somebody wants you
that was brandon
a one dollar bill and send it to them
and they sent you 25 to do that
what am i doing what is what's what's
your but you are bro
bro you're awesome i'm selling one
dollar bills for twenty five dollars
what's up that's a crispy one too that's
a
that's a good one yeah all right we this
what am i this dollar bill has
definitely not been in
it what's the
the group uh i don't know how we'd get
his address or anything
he has to uh is there an email address
on there
no he's just in the chat and he just
sent it through what am i signing you
should have sent disadvantaged
drop your email in the chat oh wait no
everyone's going to drop right now
don't put your email in the chat
everyone's going to everyone's going to
put their own email can they message the
channel directly
i don't [ __ ] don't he can send it in
the paypal message oh yeah send matt
on the paypal your address yeah so we
can match up we can match up your
your message on paypal with the money
i'm just signing yeah just
do something and you're gonna mail it to
them send a message right
like write a little message on there for
him what's your write your favorite
movie quote on there
yeah my partner in crime
oh there you go
this is awesome
he said i sent the address with 69 cents
oh nice nice selling dollars for 25
who's next
who's next baby
will you sign this book and send it to
somebody yeah
i'd do that shark in the housing pool
how much for the book
we're gonna just start signing anything
that's not nailed down in here
[Laughter]
who wants some carpet we got tons of
carpet squares
autographed hoodie uh light bulb except
the the tri dents aren't for sale except
the tridents
my old this whole dunkin donuts cup a
cold mountain dew
hold it up for us matt all right here's
what we got we got to my partner
in crime from the secret services most
wanted
and it says matthew cox
all right there we go now who am i
mailing this i gotta mail this they sent
you the address
all right you can handle that right you
know i can handle well i mean
if it's in the paypal thing i can check
paypal right yeah i'll be in the paypal
oh my god sweet that was fun anyone else
want a dollar
oh man i put this in here make sure i
don't spend it on the way home
i don't spend that [ __ ] man don't throw
that out of the strip club on your way
home no
i can't bro
so so what's your plan to get back on
track
are you are you just gonna get rich
selling books i'm not absolutely not
gonna get rich spelling but
i'll tell you what yeah that's a great
return yeah um that's what's that's what
i should have thought i should have gone
and gotten
51 dollar bills christy once christian
how is is your probation officer doing
she's she's great is she she's great
listen she watches this
she like is she however she gets every
time i say we say something she's you're
probably her favorite client
yeah you gotta be i don't know
she seems all right sometimes like
sometimes
she seems irritated by me and sometimes
that's how probation officers always
yeah they have to be that way yeah i
guess sometimes she's
totally you know hey mr cox how are you
doing yeah and then sometimes it's like
mr [ __ ] what are you doing what's going
on with this what's going on with that
it's like
like what is she asking about oh like
you know i have to do like an annual
financial thing
like like they look through all my stuff
like every month right um
well she requests she'll request stuff
um bank statements things like that
every month
so but one of the things like annually
though i have to do a full financial so
i do a full financial
and i have to fill out this
questionnaire that helps them rank
what the chances of recidivism is like
what level
how how what are the chances you're
going to recommit a crime
you know what level security you are you
should be at
so i had to fill that out the other day
and then they pull your credit so she
pulled my credit and she like contacts
me she's like
did you oh did you open a bank account
with allied bank and i was like
you know i got this text i'm like no why
and she's like there was a
an inquiry and we're just wondering i
was like i
are you not allowed to open bank
accounts no no i have to ask i have to
ask for permission for everything
wow credit cards damn car loan
um i had to get up you should have seen
me i had to beg to get a car
i'd like i really need a car my car was
basically it was done
yeah listen you couldn't drive it if you
hit the gas
it would shutter and slow down so i'd
you had to really slowly ease the gas
and then it would start going i mean it
was i would have never made it here
never would have made it here in that
car so i mean i just finally it just
and it actually stopped a couple of
times i actually had to bring it into a
place they they did something they
they said that the gas line was blown or
something just all kinds of [ __ ]
yeah bottom line is is i had to go to
her and be like listen i've got to
you've got to let me get a new vehicle
because i'd asked her before and she
said no i remember that i remember you
telling me about that she said no she
was going to buy
a vehicle cash i was like what cash you
have all my bank accounts you don't have
any money
yeah so she would be she would be
more happy if i went i think and got a
regular
job confirming with society 40 hours a
week
be a good citizen and and you know i'm
not saying that's not
that's not a possibility what i'm saying
is
that i need to give the this stuff
a try first you know and so far it
seems like i can see it you know what
i'm saying like i can see it's like when
you were talking about how you started
your channel and you said like [ __ ] for
like a year or so you said i had like
six or seven you said it took like a
year or two to get seven thousand views
or
way more than a year yeah yeah just
seven thousand subscribers
and you and you were like and then you
know just slowly creeped along then
eventually
that something happened and boom then
there was another jump and another jump
and that's where i am right now
like i'm trying to figure out
how to get subscribers and how to build
up the channel and so that i can get the
point where i can do a true crime
podcast and
you know so i've got ideas and i'm doing
it right now i'm slowly doing that but
it takes time
and it takes and it's a it's an effort
you know it's it's not it ain't easy
wait i don't know look at your [ __ ]
setup you but you make fun of my setup
all the time you say it's a little back
alley dungeon
i've never said back alley dungeon i
think i said basement
but you do have an amazing you do have
an amazing setup i just don't like the
i don't like the um the backdrop that's
all
okay i like your other backdrop better
you know when you're this backdrop this
is a 600
backdrop i don't yeah seven if you
include the rat
i don't get it we got the we got gary
sullivan
finest artwork in the background
somebody needs to buy that thing yeah
what the [ __ ]
i can't believe no one's bought the wrap
come on at least leave it here and i'll
[ __ ] put it in the background